Bonjour à tous.
Pour le 3e épisode de ma série "Crétin de cerveau" consacrée aux biais cognitifs,
on va parler des coûts irrécupérables.
Alors imaginons,
vous trouvez un super plan
pour un weekend au ski
200 € tout compris.
Du coup, vous réservez
et puis à deux jours du weekend en question
vous ne le sentez plus si bien que ça.
Vous n'êtes pas en grande forme,
à moitié malade
et puis la météo
s'annonce franchement pourrie.
Et là soudain, il y a un de vos potes
qui vous appelle
et qui vous propose de venir plutôt passer le weekend chez lui avec des amis
à regarder l'intégrale de Game of Thrones
en buvant du chocolat chaud.
Alors vous hésitez un peu,
c'est vrai que ce serait hyper sympa ce weekend série
mais vous avez déjà réservé votre weekend au ski
et ça serait con de gâcher 200€.
Du coup, vous refusez la proposition
et vous allez skier.
Et là, comme prévu, ben c'est nul.
Il fait froid, vous rentrez à moitié malade,
la neige est pourrie.
Ouais mais au moins,
vous n'avez pas gâché vos 200€.
Enfin...vous êtes sûrs ?
En vous forçant à aller au weekend ski pourri
pour "pas gâcher",
vous commettez une erreur de raisonnement,
celle dite des coûts irrécupérables.
Pour décider si vous allez au ski ou chez votre ami regarder des séries,
il faut prendre ce qui vous fait le plus plaisir.
Les 200€, ils sont déjà dépensés.
Vous ne pouvez pas les récupérer
donc ils ne devraient pas rentrer en ligne de compte.
Le choix, il est entre:
avoir payé 200€ et passer un weekend pourri au ski
et avoir payé 200€ et passer un bon weekend
à regarder des séries.
Donc la meilleure décision, il n'y a pas de débat,
c'est le weekend série.
Notre incapacité à faire abstraction
des coûts passés irrécupérables,
c'est un biais cognitif qui nous fait commettre
des erreurs de jugement
et on va voir qu'on en retrouve un peu partout.
L'histoire de ski que je viens de vous raconter
est inspirée par le scénario d'une expérience
qui a été menée dans les années 80
par deux psychologues, Arkes et Blumer,
dans ce qui est la publication de référence
sur les coûts irrécupérables.
Dans leur première expérience,
ils ont proposé le scénario suivant
à une soixantaine de personnes.
Imaginons que vous ayez réservé
deux weekends au ski.
Un dans le Michigan pour 100$
et un dans le Wisconsin pour 50$.
Et puis soudain, vous réalisez
que les deux tombent en fait à la même date.
Vous ne pouvez pas vous faire rembourser
et celui qui vous plait le plus, c'est celui du Wisconsin.
Au quel des deux vous décidez d'aller ?
Dans cette situation, plus de la moitié des gens
ont choisi le weekend du Michigan.
C'est-à-dire celui qui les intéressait le moins,
mais qu'ils avaient payé le plus cher.
Comme s'il fallait absolument
aller au weekend le plus cher
pour gâcher le moins possible.
C'est-à-dire que 50% des gens
prennent une décision irrationnelle.
L'expérience que je viens de vous décrire
est intéressante, mais ça reste un jeu de rôle,
ce n'était pas une vraie situation,
les gens répondaient à un questionnaire.
Du coup, Arkes et Blumer
ont voulu tester le biais des coûts irrécupérables
dans une situation réelle.
Pour ça, ils sont allés à la caisse d'un théâtre
qui vendait des abonnements pour toute une saison
et la saison comptait cinq pièces de théâtre.
Et puis aléatoirement, ils ont proposé à certains clients des réductions sur l'abonnement.
8$ au lieu de 15$
Ils ont ensuite suivi pendant toute la saison
combien de pièces de théâtre les gens venaient voir.
Les gens qui avaient payé leur abonnement
plein tarif, 15$,
sont allés en moyenne
voir 4,1 pièces sur 5.
Tandis que ceux qui avaient eu une réduction,
sont venus seulement 3,3 fois en moyenne.
L'interprétation des auteurs,
est que ceux qui avaient payé le plein tarif
se sentaient obligés
de rentabiliser leur abonnement plus que les autres.
Et donc ils se forçaient plus à aller voir les pièces
que ceux qui avaient eu une réduction.
Cette idée fallacieuse qu'il faille absolument rentabiliser
les dépenses passées pour "pas gâcher"
on la retrouve dans tout un tas de situations.
Des situations de la vie courante bien sûr,
mais aussi chez les hommes politiques
ou bien les managers des administrations
ou des entreprises.
C'est particulièrement vrai quand il y a des investissements,
par exemple en recherche et développement.
Pour tester ça, Arkes et Blumer
ont proposé le petit scénario suivant :
imaginons que vous soyez le PDG
d'une entreprise d'aéronautique
vous souhaitez développer
un nouvel avion furtif,
c'est-à-dire que les radars ne
peuvent pas détecter.
Le projet de recherche et développement
coûte 10 M$
et vous en avez déjà dépensé 9
et le projet est achevé à 90%.
Mais, pas de bol,
un concurrent juste avant vous
sort un avion furtif moins cher et plus performant
que celui que vous êtes en train de développer.
La question c'est :
est-ce que vous dépensez 1 M$
pour compléter le projet ?
Sur ce petit scénario fictif,
le "oui" l'a emporté à 85%,
c'est-à-dire que 85% des gens décidaient de dépenser
le million de dollars supplémentaire
pour terminer le projet.
À un second groupe de participants,
on a proposé une variante du scénario.
La situation de départ est absolument identique
sauf que le projet de R&D coûte seulement 1 M$,
mais qu'il n'a pas commencé.
Et donc la question c'est,
"êtes-vous prêt à dépenser 1 M$
pour faire le projet ?"
Eh ben là, c'est le non qui a été choisi à 83%.
Et pourtant, si vous regardez bien,
dans les deux scénarios
la question est absolument la même.
Il s'agit de savoir si on est prêt à mettre 1 M$
pour développer un avion
dont on sait qu'il sera moins performant
que celui du concurrent.
On peut avoir de bonnes raisons
de le faire ou de ne pas le faire,
mais la réponse ne devrait pas différer
dans les deux scénarios.
Le raisonnement fallacieux
lié aux coûts irrécupérables
a tendance à créer des situations
où on dépense toujours plus
pour rentabiliser les investissements passés.
Et donc, on a une espèce d'escalade des coûts,
même si on sait que le projet, à la fin,
ne sera pas rentable.
On retrouve souvent ça en politique.
Il y a un cas fameux qui est discuté
par Arkes et Blumer,
c'est le projet de canal dit Tenn-Tom,
aux Étas-Unis, entre le Tennessee et l'Alabama.
Même après son commencement,
ce projet a été pas mal remis en question
et on a des citations d'hommes politiques
qui défendaient le projet avec des arguments du genre :
__
Eh ben non, biais des coûts irrécupérables.
En France, il y a un cas fameux qui est assez similaire,
c'est celui du développement du Concorde.
Même si les gouvernements britanniques et français
savaient au bout d'un moment
que le projet serait un échec commercial,
ils ont choisi de continuer le projet Concorde
pour ne pas gâcher l'agent
déjà investi dans le développement.
Le cas est tellement fameux
que dans la littérature scientifique,
le biais des coûts irrécupérables est parfois appelé: l'effet Concorde.
Il y a un autre exemple politique qui est très connu,
ce sont les arguments qui ont été avancés par certains Américains pour ne pas se retirer du Vietnam
et qui donnaient des justifications du genre:
trop de vies de soldats ont déjà été perdues
et si on se retire maintenant,
elles l'auront été pour rien.
Et pareil, c'est un coût irrécupérable,
il ne devrait pas rentrer en ligne de compte
dans la décision.
Sur une note plus légère,
il y a un auteur qui a étudié
l'effet des coûts irrécupérables
sur les décisions prises
par les coachs de basket.
Vous savez peut-être qu'en NBA
et dans d'autres sports US,
il y a un processus qui permet aux équipes
d'aller piocher à tour de rôle
des joueurs dans le championnat universitaire.
Ça s'appelle la draft.
Et donc, il y a une publication qui montre
qu'à performances égales,
plus un joueur a été choisi tôt dans la draft,
plus le coach va le faire jouer,
comme s'il fallait absolument le rentabiliser
même s'il n'était pas si bon que ça.
Bon allez, assez d'exemples maintenant,
regardons un peu les considérations théoriques.
Du point de vue de la théorie économique,
prendre une décision, c'est relativement simple.
Il suffit de comparer les coûts et les bénéfices
attendus des différentes options.
Et quand on fait ça,
on ne doit prendre en compte que les coûts futurs,
Ceux sur lesquels on a un levier d'action.
Les coûts passés qui sont irrécupérables
ne devraient pas rentrer en ligne de compte.
Enfin, ça, c'est le comportement rationnel.
Ce qu'on vient de voir,
c'est que dans tout un tas de situations
ben ce n'est pas ce qu'on fait.
On se comporte de manière
fondamentalement irrationnelle.
Et ça, c'est une observation très importante
parce qu'il y a énormément de travaux en économie,
et notamment dans ce qu'on appelle
la micro-économie,
qui font l'hypothèse
que tout le monde se comporte toujours
de manière parfaitement rationnelle,
prend toujours les meilleures décisions dans son intérêt
et ne commet jamais d'erreur de raisonnement.
Et on vient de voir
que le biais des coûts irrécupérables,
c'est quand même une sérieuse entorse
à cette hypothèse.
Ces comportements irrationnels
dans des choix économiques,
il en existe plein d'autres,
je vous en parlerai dans d'autres vidéos.
Ils sont à l'origine d'un champ d'étude,
situé à la frontière entre l'économie et la psychologie,
et qu'on appelle l'économie comportementale.
Ce courant a notamment été fondé et largement étudié
par Kahneman et Tversky,
dont j'ai déjà parlé dans ma vidéo sur l'effet d'ancrage.
Maintenant qu'on a constaté ce biais
de notre crétin de cerveau,
est-ce qu'on peut essayer de l'expliquer ?
L'explication la plus élémentaire,
c'est tout simplement le fait
qu'on nous a toujours répété qu'il ne fallait pas gâcher.
C'est vrai, d'une manière générale,
il ne faut pas gâcher,
mais là, ce raisonnement, il ne s'applique pas.
On parle de coûts passés qui sont irrécupérables,
donc il n'y a rien à gâcher ou à économiser.
Autre explication au fait que nos choix
soient influencés par les coûts irrécupérables,
c'est notre volonté de ne pas perdre la face.
Ne pas perdre la face en public, bien sûr,
c'est vrai pour les hommes politiques
ou bien les managers dans les entreprises,
mais aussi ne pas perdre la face en privé.
Parce qu'en fait
on déteste se remettre en question,
on déteste admettre à nous-même
qu'on a eu tort.
On préfère rester avec nos certitudes passées
plutôt que de reconnaître qu'on s'est trompé.
D'ailleurs, il y a une expérience fascinante
qui montre très bien cet effet.
Elle ressemble un peu à celle de l'avion furtif.
On a pris un groupe d'étudiants
et on les a mis face au choix suivant :
vous êtes à la tête d'une entreprise,
vous avez 20 M$ à dépenser
et vous avez le choix entre un projet d'investissement A
et puis un projet B.
Et puis on leur fournit tout un tas de documents,
de données financières sur l'entreprise,
les deux projets possibles,
le contexte économique, etc.
Et on leur demande de choisir
entre investir dans le projet A
ou investir dans le projet B.
Et puis, deuxième étape,
on leur donne de nouveaux documents
qui leur montrent qu'au bout d'un an,
finalement leur choix n'était pas terrible.
Les résultats sont mauvais.
Mais on leur donne à nouveau 20 M$
qu'on leur demande de répartir entre poursuivre
le projet qu'ils avaient choisi initialement
et démarrer l'autre projet.
Et puis à un 2e groupe d'étudiants,
en fait on leur soumet exactement la même histoire
mais on les fait commencer directement
à la 2e étape.
C'est-à-dire qu'on leur explique
que quelqu'un d'autre, leur prédécesseur,
a choisi tel projet,
que ça a donné des résultats bof bof
et on leur donne les mêmes documents
et on leur demande comment répartir leurs 20 M$
entre le projet déjà commencé par leur prédécesseur
et le nouveau projet.
Le biais des coûts irrécupérables nous dit
qu'on va avoir tendance à persister dans le même projet
pour ne pas gâcher l'argent qui a déjà été investi.
Et c'est effectivement ce qui se passe.
Les étudiants du 2e groupe
persistent à donner de l'argent au projet initial
et ils allouent en moyenne 9 M$ à ce projet.
Et les étudiants du 1er groupe, eux,
ils vont donner en moyenne 13 M$ à leur projet initial.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils sont encore plus pris
que les autres
par le raisonnement qui dit
qu'il ne faut pas gâcher l'argent déjà investi.
Et pourquoi ?
Parce que ce sont eux
qui avaient décidé d'investir.
Le simple fait d'avoir été à l'origine
responsable de la dépense initiale
nous englue encore plus
dans le biais des coûts irrécupérables.
Ah oui, et le plus inquiétant,
c'est que je vous ai dit que les sujets
de cette expérience étaient des étudiants
mais c'était des étudiants en gestion et commerce.
C'est-à-dire ceux qui dirigent les entreprises aujourd'hui.
Bon de toute façon,
de manière générale,
le fait de s'y connaître en économie
ne protège pas du biais des coûts irrécupérables.
La preuve, c'est que Arkes et Blumer
ont refait leur expérience du weekend de ski
vous savez, le Michigan à 100$
ou le Wisconsin à 50$...
Mais avec trois types d'étudiants.
Des étudiants en psychologie,
des étudiants en psychologie
ayant suivi un cours d'économie
et des étudiants en économie.
Et point important, dans les cours d'économie,
on apprenait ce que je suis en train de vous raconter.
C'est-à-dire qu'on apprenait
le biais des coûts irrécupérables.
Eh ben voilà les résultats.
Environ 1/3 des étudiants se sont fait avoir,
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont fait le choix irrationnel
d'aller dans le Michigan.
Et ça, indépendamment de leur cursus.
Comme quoi,
même le fait de savoir qu'il existe
ne nous protège pas
du biais des coûts irrécupérables.
Ce biais, je le trouve vraiment incroyable
parce qu'il me semble
que c'est un des plus puissant que je connaisse.
Même après vous avoir fait toute cette vidéo
sur le sujet,
j'ai encore du mal à me convaincre moi-même.
Je crois que s'il m'arrivait
la situation que je vous ai décrite au début de la vidéo,
vous savez le weekend ski
vs weekend Game of Thrones,
je ne suis pas sûr que j'arriverais à prendre
la bonne décision.
Je dois vraiment être crétin.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo.
Si elle vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à la partager
pour faire connaître autour de vous
le biais des coûts irrécupérables.
Vous pouvez retrouver les actualités de la chaîne
sur Facebook, Twitter,
vous pouvez me soutenir sur tipee,
merci beaucoup à tous ceux qui me soutiennent.
On se retrouve dans environ deux semaines
pour une nouvelle vidéo
avant une petite pause estivale bien méritée.
Merci et à bientôt.